[Music]
all they are showing all day today I
don't care if you're watching the news I
don't care if you're watching a daytime
talk show every every show all they're
doing is airing footage of the president
and the first lady at the inaugural ball
I have to say on a personal level I felt
kind of kind of bad for them because I
thought it must be hard to do something
so intimate as to slow-dance in front of
the whole world you know their man is
hussars they're slow dancing it you
don't I mean there's no way I could do
it I mean it just it's too creepy in a
way you know it just feels to me like
it's such an intimate moment between a
couple and I just felt like an invasion
of privacy to me you know yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
we got a great show tonight from the 8th
time on Spadina till silver linings
playbook and the upcoming ABC movie the
makeover Julia Stiles
[Applause]
from the new FX series legit DJ calls
Meisel guess the lovin bellow
[Applause]
[Music]
you